[Music]
okay
now i'm worried about the volume all
right how's the volume sound everybody
because the volume last night i couldn't
figure out why it wasn't working
correctly
yeah you know what i mean yeah you got
to make sure that the the microphone
volume is good because now it's like now
i don't want it to be like way too loud
and everyone's like
stop it says it's getting good signal
how's the sound everybody
make it stop volume is good okay that's
good
volume is good i mean i turned it up so
it's like
i don't know why i don't know the
settings were the same as they always
been and then suddenly last night it was
like super super quiet
cat sabotaged that's what i suspect all
right this is all right
all right so um today we're going to
talk about this damn
korean zombie movie that we saw uh the
other day
well it wasn't last night i think it was
the night before last week yeah we
watched it like a couple nights ago
now we all know that the top number one
korean zombie movie is trained to busan
hard to beat that one yeah i mean that's
hard to be really [ __ ] good movie but
i tell you what
this one's right there with it i like
that
it's called hashtag alive yeah it's only
got like a couple of characters in it
and it's uh not so much action they're
more like survival
they're trapped in the damn apartment
building so
that's the way they come with this
instead of going all over korea and all
these different places and
on the train trapped on the train
they're just trapped in the apartment so
there's always little practical things
that they have to do to get around this
[ __ ]
zombie pandemic they're pretty much kind
of like the same zombies when you say
they're pretty much the same zombies
they look similar like with the white
eyes and the kind and they're fast
and they're not technically i guess
they're not technically they're more
like 28 days later like rage zombies
because i don't think they're
technically
dead are they yeah they're dead oh yeah
they're dead so
they come back to life but it comes back
but it's it's hard to
like it's kind of hard to say because
sometimes people get bit and then they
just go
yeah and then they turn into you know
zombies so you don't really know if they
died or if they just like got involved
that's why it wasn't trying to boost on
that's true trying to boost they would
turn almost immediately you get bit and
within a few minutes you were going to
turn
which yeah you'd be super hosed if that
happened yeah and uh
they kind of remember who they were and
certain things they have skills
opening doors and pressing buttons
climbing buildings climbing things
yeah so but that's the way they weren't
training busan
yeah so it it looks like the the movie
was written to fit right in with trying
to busan almost kind of like you know
what i mean
like fanfics not really fanfic but extra
canonical
because it's not the same it's not the
same people yeah because like
it's almost kind of like it's the same
outbreak but happening somewhere else
yeah yeah it's like the same outbreak
but it's happening in another place like
in another part of it and it seems to be
the damn same zombies
and uh it's kind of it's kind of neat
you know what i mean it's like a dude's
trapped into his apartment he doesn't
know what to do
his parents are gone he's a kid not
really yeah well he's a teenager
or early 20s and i guess like he's i
guess his job is he's like a video game
live streamer because he's got like in
his room he's got like all the
equipment like all the screens and
everything like that so i guess that's
what he does
but he's in the apartment alone and i
guess normally
his parents and sister also live there
but they have gone somewhere else i
don't i don't even know if they said
like where they went but they're like
they didn't make it back they weren't
they they were at the dad's office
weren't they or something like that yeah
they had gone somewhere and he
yeah so they got separated and he didn't
have any food in the apartment or not
much yeah he got pretty quick
and he had to start drinking the booze
to stay alive because then the water
went out which
yeah hey booze has water in it yeah
that's what i said when i was watching i
was like
that's legit and he's got tv he's got tv
but it doesn't have a real good
online connection it's intermittent and
they have power i think through most of
most of the movie but the water goes out
yeah the water goes out before the power
does
yeah and he's trapped in an apartment
building and uh
you know he doesn't know whether or not
he's in there by himself
and eventually finds out there are a few
other people in there i can't really
spoil it
but what's it called it's called hashtag
what elias alive yeah hashtag alive
that's the name of it it's on
netflix and uh i recommend it it's good
it's real good yeah i really liked it
like i said
it has the the nice thing about this and
also about trying to busan the weird
thing about this movie though which i
didn't actually realize
was that this movie was actually written
by
a hollywood screenwriter named matt
naylor he wrote it back in 2019
and it was initially called hashtag
alone
and then he started collaborating with
um the director of this movie
joe wilhyung and then they kind of like
collaborated on the script and like got
it to where they wanted and then they
made the movie like together
so i thought that was kind of
interesting that it wasn't you know
originally it was just like
some american dudes mango saying that
um china was amazing but he heard he
didn't hear very good things about the
scene oh that's a bomber
i didn't know this i didn't know the
sequel was out yet
yeah i thought it wasn't out yet either
or that i thought it was going to come
out like pretty soon though
right i mean i thought what what's the
name of the sequel i can't remember i
just
might i totally had a brain more like a
part post peninsula
something like that it's more of a
post-apocalyptic movie
yeah which kind of like because it's
it's sometime after the the outbreak
and uh you know it's kind of gone
walking dead on them
you know crosstalking walking dead at
mad max i'm still i'm still gonna give
it a
a fair shot well yeah i don't take other
people's words for it i got to really
see it myself
um i like the first one i'm ahead and
trust that maybe the second one will
at least be decent but this one's good
if you like training busan you'll like
this one
yeah because i think they do a good job
of mixing
in um character drama
with the zombie apocalypse this one is
not quite as
because i think train to busan is like
more frenetic like more action-packed
because it's like this train is moving
and it's just like everywhere they stop
like like there's zombies there's a lot
of characters and there's try
yeah and they're like all the stuff this
is kind of a more intimate like
and it's more based around survival and
it's based around this guy being alone
stuck in his apartment he doesn't know
what to do he's running out of food
there's like zombies everywhere
and um so it gives you kind of for me i
liked it because it
kind of had elements of a mega man in it
a little bit
yeah of you know with charlton heston a
kid but he's a young kid he's not
military guy he's just trying to figure
out how to [ __ ] survive
and uh it gets depressing for him it's
good it's a good movie
yeah so like i said it's kind of it's i
think that's what a lot of people like
um
you know responded so well to trying to
boost on is you really really gave a
[ __ ] about the characters you cared
about them
because they took some time you know
establishing these characters and making
you like them
and then they're in these you know
terrible situations and you're thinking
oh [ __ ] like what would i do in that
situation and [ __ ] like that so they're
really good at doing that
and um so you know this poor guy and
then like the other
people that he meets along the way yeah
and
another thing too there's and like i
said i'm not going to spoil it
but there's one point where
they meet another person and oh
that did not go the way i expected
[Laughter]
sandra's she pulled out the chest and
that's right chester the chest and
chest like chest and keep your [ __ ]
shirt on bro
yeah yeah don't take your shirt off
justin but yeah
what are you thinking chest well like i
said back in the old roster could take
his shirt off not chested
yeah like i said well and the thing
about it is that and when we were
talking about the charles bronson thing
i didn't even realize he was that
he was that jacked because you know i
hadn't seen like a lot of his
older movies and like by the time he got
famous over here he was like a lot older
and wasn't taking his shirt off which
everyone probably appreciated but
it really did seem like i think in the
60s and 70s
you know the the standards weren't you
know as high if you if you as long as
you were a guy and you weren't like
you know super fat or anything like that
you know bronson would you check your
shirt off
bronson was jacked well into his back
yeah well into his late 50s yeah
i mean he was looking great in his 40s a
lot of people didn't realize he was that
old
yeah it wasn't really until he was in
his 60s and 70s you know what i mean
you could tell you could tell bronson
drank
yeah i think he [ __ ] jokes well we
all do he's sitting there you know he
drank a lot
everybody did that yeah and he was he
spent a lot of time on that damn
farm that he had it's not getting all
day getting all weathered he didn't give
a [ __ ]
yeah he made his money but um
yeah this is a good movie just just got
to say i'm going to give it three thumbs
up and i only got two
three thumbs up yes tom enjoyed this one
very well i enjoyed it as well
i give it three thumbs up on the back of
no hollywood [ __ ]
it's just it doesn't feel like a
hollywood [ __ ] movie just feels like
they're going to tell you a [ __ ]
story
yeah i mean they're not compromising i
liked it
yeah i did too and like i said i liked
the way um
they kind of i i like when they thrust
somebody that is not necessarily
who you'd want on your side earning a
zombie apocalypse
but they kind of like learn as they go
and like
figure stuff out and like so i really
like the way he kind of like went on and
you know and yeah he gets depressed and
yeah he thinks like you know there's no
point or anything but then like he kind
of
gets hope back and like you know rallies
to the cause
i'm really hoping that dune is not a
hollywood movie
uh the the [ __ ] trailer looks very
good
uh but the blade runner sequel was great
i liked it
and those movies they weren't weren't
compromising
all right they were just gonna tell you
the [ __ ] story um if they were
compromising and going through a damn
checklist you see i hate i hate movies
that are built by a committee
and a hollywood movie is built by a
[ __ ] committee and they're going to
go down through a checklist and [ __ ]
how are we going to [ __ ] you know uh
uh
pander to all these different kinds of
people in the same movie how are we
gonna
make a movie that everybody like when
you start trying to make a movie that
everybody likes
nobody's gonna like it it's gonna be
well yeah you can't you can't appeal to
everybody you just can't and
it's like there's no point in trying
watered down [ __ ]
hollywood fake tentpole movie that
nobody sees nowadays that their shit's
[ __ ] crumbling
at least in korea they're not big budget
movies there aren't a bunch of [ __ ]
producers with their hands in the pot
going
i gotta triple my investment right i
gotta triple my investment
and then all these [ __ ] uh you know
advertising companies going well to do
it this way we're having
run around all this [ __ ] corporate
jargon and next thing you know you got a
piece of [ __ ] movie
with no artistic value at all no
artistic vision
it's just a generic [ __ ] [ __ ]
movie
the koreans don't have aren't these are
not big budget movies and they're not
trying to sell them everywhere they're
just trying to
sell them to koreans yeah this was
specifically even though it was
initially written by an american the
script
um him and the director you know wrote
it for the korean market
yeah and it actually when they released
it over there because i think it came
out in late june over there
um on i don't know if it came out in
theaters or just came out on streaming
but it was actually hugely successful it
took like you know 60
70 of like the box office that week when
it came out
well i'm gonna [ __ ] go ahead and give
my testimony let me testify
let me testify jenny i'm gonna give my
testimonial
because it's marketed towards the korean
peninsula
they're not giving a [ __ ] so what you
end up with this is a movie that's
[ __ ] not compromising
and sticking to basics of good
storytelling so it ends up being
appealing everywhere
well yeah because they [ __ ] wrote a
good don't these hollywood
[ __ ] need to stop listening to these
corporate wind bags
just make a good [ __ ] movie don't try
to sell it to everybody make a good
movie and everyone will buy into it
if it's good you can't do it with your
damn checklists
well like i said too you can't make
everyone happy there's always some
people that aren't going to like it no
matter what you do so it's like don't
worry and
and here's the thing this movie wasn't
trying to make everybody happy but it
made everybody happy because it was a
good quality story
yeah that's all and like i said i think
on the back of it being
so successful in korea yeah netflix
picked it up
yeah you know in september it just it
just came on the platform like september
10th september 12th like just like a
couple days ago
and um it just immediately shot to
number one not just in the u.s but like
all over europe and [ __ ] like that so
like you said they didn't make it for a
worldwide audience
really all you got to do is look at
mulan now tammy's in there going preach
tom
i'm testifying it's not it's beyond
preaching okay
i'm testifying testifying before the
court okay
mulan is a great example of trying to
make everybody [ __ ] happy and that
[ __ ] is [ __ ] bombing
all right they tried to go for this
[ __ ] global appeal it doesn't work
because the the audience member watching
this movie is not the globe
he's an individual he or she is an
individual person
if you just [ __ ] tell a story that an
individual person
can relate to you don't have to worry
about that global [ __ ] that [ __ ] comes
automatically
you know what i mean yeah they're
watering the [ __ ] down with this global
[ __ ]
just tell a good [ __ ] story that an
individual viewer can relate to
and it's usually just the basics simple
basic [ __ ]
a good character a problem that's got to
be solved
people trying to figure out the [ __ ]
solution to the problem
[ __ ] happens it's exciting when this
[ __ ] happens and then even
worse [ __ ] worship it's very [ __ ]
simple a low budget
movie from [ __ ] thailand about a dude
trapping it down pool with the alligator
did a [ __ ] perfect job of it
i loved that movie i really did and this
is a [ __ ]
low budget movie okay but it was from
the heart
hollywood can't even come close to that
anymore because it's got its head up its
ass
there's too many damn corporate [ __ ]
no-nothings in there telling too many
cooks in the kitchen that's all i'm
trying to say well and like i said
they're too worried
they're too worried about money too
worried about money too many goddamn
cooks in the kitchen i mean everybody
wants their movie to be successful
nobody wants it to be terrible and lose
money but right
that can't be your only concern you have
to make like
and it's funny that you brought up that
time movie the pool because it's like
i when we were watching that movie and i
think we said it on the review i was
just like now this
is how you make like a low budget one
location movie
yeah it's just this poor guy in this
terrible situation
and then it just keeps ramping up and
ramping up and ramping up
just like worst [ __ ] keeps happening to
the dude and you're like no
the premise is [ __ ] ridiculous it is
he falls into the goddamn pool
and there's no water in it and he can't
get out of the [ __ ] pool
and the alligators and then there's a
crocodile and that's just the beginning
of the [ __ ] problem and then it just
gets worse
and it was an entertaining low-budget
movie that fulfilled
the audience by watching it and today's
hollywood
can't even [ __ ] come close to that
you could give a they're going to try to
make a billion-dollar movie you watch
this [ __ ] and you're like that [ __ ]
[ __ ] sucked
because it doesn't it doesn't speak to
you yeah it's like and even if it
doesn't suck it's just like not all that
memorable it's just kind of like huh
it's like you got onto a ride at
disneyland and you got off and you were
what happened
yeah yeah and it's kind of fun while
you're watching it but then you don't
remember it right
didn't didn't really didn't really speak
to you on a human level
that was like the problem with marvel
movies i'll be kind of enjoying them
when i'm watching them and then when
they're gone i'm like what happened
what was that movie about sometimes i
don't even remember
if i saw them or not later yeah like
even though i enjoyed them at the time i
was just kind of like
like a month later i'd be like wait did
i see them we saw in we saw end game and
evidently it wrapped up a whole bunch of
other movies that i didn't see
but yeah i just saw some of them yeah i
was kind of behind but i just had a
feeling that
end game is kind of like the end of that
game
well that's what it was kind of meant
yeah i don't think i i don't think
that's a sustainable model it's like
you're only going to be able to make
so many lord of the rings movies i mean
i liked the i
i liked the offshoot movies that marvel
started making like into the spider
verse
yeah that was all right man i liked into
the spider verse a lot that was like
really cool i would watch more of that
you know i had all the spider-man's i
wanted to see more of the art nouveau
or the art deco spider-man the black and
white spider-man the yeah the noir
spider-man noir
they should yeah they should totally do
a spin-off of like yeah i'd even watch
the whole series about them
yeah just cartoon or the little pig one
was kind of funny too yeah
but i don't know that's all i got to say
about it but yeah this so i think the
same
the same things that we liked about the
pool
was the same things that i liked about
this it was focused very much on
you know one or two characters he was
somebody that was put in like a shitty
situation
and he was just like an average dude so
a lot of people could like relate to him
and be like oh [ __ ] man like what do you
do
now and he didn't really do anything he
didn't seem to do anything like
intensely stupid or anything i mean he
figured [ __ ] out like along the way
yeah and um you know and like i said it
was kind of like the pool where it's
like you know he'd have a little success
but then like [ __ ] would get worse and
then like you know and he just had to
kind of go through it and
but you know it's it's just a really
decent a really
really decent like zombie movie what i'm
going to say you know [ __ ] ken's
telling me that i need to be running
hollywood
how it was running itself into the
ground just let that
let that titanic that titanic already
hit the iceberg
it will regroup they just have to get
rid of all that old blood
they have to get rid of all that money
it'll just regroup into like smaller
studios exactly that'll make like kind
of smaller more more niche kind of films
which is fine with me movies that are
that are more story based
because you have to understand what
they're emulating is low budget movies
terminator one was low budget predator
one was low budget
all right but they were really well
written they were fun to [ __ ] watch
and they try to recapture that [ __ ]
lightning in the bottle by just throwing
money at the problem
that's not how you do it it's writing
it's about characters
it's about story yeah if you don't have
a good script
you don't have a good movie and then
they want to come up and go well we have
to fill this diversity checklist because
those old movies [ __ ] weren't
not diverse and they sucked i don't know
what movie you saw
predator one was diverse as [ __ ] they
had a diverse cast but that [ __ ] worked
because it was a good [ __ ] story and
you believed it
and really you could say well arnold was
a star it was an
all our movie in a way it was all right
but if you go back and really analyze
predator one
it's more like a carl weathers movie
carl [ __ ] holds that movie together
if if carl wasn't in that movie
that movie would not it would be okay it
would not be a [ __ ] classic
because the reason why that movie
has stood the test of time and i'm
getting off [ __ ]
topic i know you guys like this [ __ ] the
reason why that movie stood the test of
time it was on the back
of the [ __ ] scenes that had carl
and [ __ ] arnold doing a scene
together
because carl can act it gave that movie
gravitas it made everything else
serious well yeah it like
i said it made everything believable
made everything believable right
and that's all on the back of script and
character yeah like i said if you don't
have that you don't have a good movie if
people don't give a [ __ ] yeah and you're
in
them and there's a lot of subtext
because it was
the story was originally written by
veterans all right
you have two you have carl and you have
[ __ ] arnold
i'm gonna call them uh [ __ ] what was it
[ __ ] what was their names
dutch and what was [ __ ] cause
whether it's um dylan okay dutch and
dylan
they were the same character really all
right but they were in a they were the
same
kind of alpha male warrior kind of guy
but they were opposites you had one that
was a stand-up
play by the rules alpha male
fighter but then you have carl and he
was more like a sigma male i guess you
could say
and he was cia working in the shadows he
he wasn't a stand-up fighter he was a
kind of he would he would lie to get
[ __ ] done
because he grew up he said that you know
but in the end
in the end [ __ ] it it works out
the both of them were fighting to
[ __ ] against the same enemy
they were both kind of men of honor they
just had two different styles of doing
it
and the reason why the reason why
uh [ __ ] dylan was lying is because he
was avenging the death of all the other
guys that died fighting the predator
that he sent down there
i'm getting i'm getting ahead of him
looking bored
well you could talk about it if you want
all right i mean we already we already
reviewed i already talked about it but
yeah yeah
he was lying to [ __ ] to get
to get guys down there to avenge the
death of his teams that he sent there
before
remember the guys that they found in the
helicopter and he was just going to do
it any way he possibly could
and that was but in the end he died for
that and he
i wouldn't want to say atoned
that's not really a way to look at it it
was him
dying against that thing and being
killed was proof
that he wasn't doing this [ __ ]
ultimately for selfish reasons that he
was willing
to die for it too which that's really
the subtext of that movie that's that's
what made that movie for me
great a great movie not a good movie but
a great movie well yeah is that they
died
yeah you know man they died for the [ __ ]
yeah and
um so dylan was i guess you could say
uh proven to be a man of honor by dying
for it
yeah okay so yeah that's all i gotta say
but that kind of writing is what
me it wasn't the [ __ ] special effects
that was only part of it
it was the writing yeah that's what made
that well like i said
if you don't have a good and i feel like
writers are kind of like
underrated like in a lot of movie making
because if you don't have
a good if you don't have good writers
and see yeah
jenny's a writer she knows all right if
you don't have a good [ __ ] writer
you're not working with anything
because no one's going to care about
what happens
in your story and if nobody cares what
happens in your story
then it's not going to be a good movie
because no one's going to give a [ __ ]
and a problem with a lot of the [ __ ]
modern hollywood movies there's too many
goddamn characters
that was a big problem with star wars
they're trying to [ __ ]
fulfill a [ __ ] checklist for [ __ ]
representation and all kinds of
they're not just telling a good story
they're going through corporate [ __ ]
to try to make the movie appeal to every
single [ __ ] person
and they're trying to do it based on
color but man i was identifying with
guys that are black you know what i mean
in the movies i don't they don't have to
look like me for that to identify with
them
that's that's some stupid marketing
agent saying that that's not how
how it goes [ __ ] one of my great
heroes growing up [ __ ] it was axel
foley
that character yeah i [ __ ] love
beverly hills cop you know
my buddies wanted to grow up to be eddie
murphy you were white
so i don't really understand where this
shit's coming from you know what i mean
[Laughter]
because we thought that was [ __ ]
awesome he's a cop
okay but he's telling you he wasn't
always a cop
and then he's breaking these rules and
[ __ ] he's outside his jurisdiction
he's breaking into [ __ ] you know and
then he's [ __ ]
doing his own forensics using super glue
and
you know to look for [ __ ]
fingerprints to avenge
his friend who got killed by the detroit
mob
for gangster [ __ ] that they were doing
yeah but he was a good guy
he wasn't a bad guy he was a good guy
all right he was uh uh
he was a guy who had turned over a new
leaf and become
a a a detective but he he didn't come
out and say it but you know that at one
time he was a criminal
and i just thought that was a [ __ ]
great and it was funny as [ __ ] yeah
and had away with women and could talk
his way in and out of things
kind of like fletch in a way but and i
just
man we just growing up watching saturday
night live we just [ __ ] love that
dude so i don't really know
about all this racial representation
[ __ ] we never [ __ ]
had that issue this is an issue they're
making up all those movies were diverse
like the thing
you know what i mean yeah childs childs
and mccready you know what i mean that
[ __ ] was just [ __ ]
worked you know what i mean and it was a
diverse it was a diverse
cast but it wasn't didn't feel like it
was done artificially on purpose to fill
a checklist
they were just who they just who they
just were who they were
you know yeah and i was identifying
not only with mccready but with you know
with childs too
so i i i don't i'm calling [ __ ] on
hollywood
people are people the people are just
people yeah
i'm just saying yeah but yeah so like i
said this this movie
um you know it did really well in korea
like we were talking about before
and then when it came out on netflix all
over the world it was number one
in 35 different countries
including the us including spain france
sweden
russia australia canada all over the
place so everybody loves them
some korean [ __ ] zombie movies
especially when they're good like this
one
we've seen a lot of really good korean
movies lately haven't we actually
but yeah this has uh 91 or rotten
tomatoes so yeah
yeah they're also guys are also saying
that bill duke was the [ __ ] and predator
yes he was the [ __ ] and i'm gonna get me
something
i'm gonna get me something that [ __ ]
he's running up there with his [ __ ]
60
his short braille 60 yeah i'm all happy
i love that dude yeah he just [ __ ]
carried himself is just as a badass you
know
almost er almost all those dudes in that
movie was some kind of veteran
a lot of them were uh either you know
vietnam v vietnam era
veterans and they knew how to [ __ ]
become those roles because they were
familiar with it you know
yeah great movie great movie it will
predator one will [ __ ]
be up there it'll stand the test of time
forever it'll be up there with alien
one and two and terminator one it's just
difficult to beat those movies in that
genre
even commando wasn't bad i liked
commander
bill dick was in that too yeah it was
more fun it's more like watching a video
game
some it's like watching somebody play a
video game yeah and there's something
about the score
with the music going what the [ __ ]
you know with the damn [ __ ] caribbean
sounding [ __ ]
percussion going you know it was good
man radon showing on
yeah you know and i wasn't trying to be
something that wasn't
it was purely what it was a [ __ ]
fast-paced
action movie with a hero that you rooted
for and he
went through boss fights basically yeah
like like a [ __ ] scroll side
scrolling video game
like ghosts and goblins or some [ __ ]
like that remember that game
uh vaguely yeah
all right but yeah if you have netflix
and you have not yet watched
watched alive and you like trying to
busan you like other korean
zombie movies you like zombie just good
zombie movies in general
then i would definitely recommend it
it's pretty kick-ass um
so check it out are you done yeah are we
shutting the [ __ ] down yeah they're
talking about
having some fun tonight that's that's
[ __ ] yeah
matt he's playing mac yeah that was a
[ __ ] great character
i see you yeah yeah like
i think he would he might he was
probably my favorite character in there
but like i said we're all good
i love bill duke and everything like
he's so [ __ ] rad he has like such a
great face and a great voice
yeah they were all he was upside down
all sweating out in that [ __ ] jungle
[ __ ] you know trying to get
underneath the damn log and that little
three [ __ ] dots hit him on the head
they were real [ __ ] good about how
they edited that that you knew it blew
his
a big hole in his head but you didn't
really see it happen
yeah you know i mean they were [ __ ]
they were very good with the editing
back then
and [ __ ] it was just that movie was
just made with love you know
now it's a problem made with just made
with love
[Laughter]
they're taking me the audience is taking
me back
and i want to see it again well you can
watch it you have it i have it yeah yeah
you can go you can go in the room and
watch it right now
yeah because you know it's the future
yeah it's the future go watch whatever i
want to watch it
what a time to be alive it's a good
movie yeah then you
compare that to the new predator that
came out i have that one too and i tried
to watch it again i liked it in a
theater
all right but i tried to watch it again
and man just the flow of that movie is
not right
it was all right but it wasn't fantastic
it's the way the edit and the way that
that thing flowed
that it's just not right it's not bad
it's just not right
yeah it's something it needed some
tweaking yeah it's just not right the
way they have that thing i think if
they'd have tweaked it a little bit it
would have been
that's true actually it it's too slow
it's too complicated they're trying to
tell too many stories at once there's
something
something's not right about it i have to
go back and totally analyze it
yeah but i tried to watch it again and i
just wasn't falling in love with it
and i just stopped it about [ __ ] an
hour into it i was like you know what i
don't really care
and that's the problem with it yeah you
know yeah it's just
yeah it was all right but it was just
kind of like yeah man yeah
yeah cause yeah we saw in the theater
didn't we yeah and it was better in the
theater because you have to sit through
it
and you don't know what's gonna happen
you don't have to you can get up
whatever you want
you feel like yeah and you don't know
what's gonna happen
but it's not one that's real repeatable
predator two
it was easier to re repeat really
predator three
is the best one besides predator one
yeah
i liked that one yeah i did too yeah
uh have either of you seen rorschach
it's on youtube
uh i have not seen it yet but i will
have to watch it
on your recommendation but yeah so uh we
will be back tomorrow doing another live
stream
uh i think pretty sure we already
watched the movie that we're gonna
because i watched another new one
that we can review tomorrow so uh i'm
not gonna spoil it tell you what it is
well we'll be back tomorrow at the 3 p.m
eastern standard time doing another live
stream talking yes
hold on yes i did like alien versus
predator films they were okay go ahead
yeah i think i saw the first one in the
theater but i don't and i liked it but i
don't think i saw any of the others
there's two of them and they're both
okay they're at least at least to their
movies
you know they're movies they should put
that in the front of the box at least it
was a movie
well here's the thing here's the thing
people are trying to go back and [ __ ]
compare it to aliens and predators and
[ __ ] and
they're not perfect okay the second one
is a little dark but they're trying to
hide the fact that the special effects
aren't all that good
but at least it was a movie and they
were entertaining
they're even the one with the pyramid
under under it was entertaining
and then with the one running around
[ __ ] melting the [ __ ] in the swimming
pool
it was entertaining yeah you know they
weren't perfect but
it was at least a bonus movie you could
see it yeah you know
ken keeps uh he asked me if i saw a
serbian film i you know what i've seen
like parts of it i probably should sit
through it one of these days
i know what happens in it because i've
read the wikipedia uh you know summary
i don't know that's i feel like i don't
know is in a lot of ways like movies
like that don't really bother me
um but i've seen so many people comment
it's like well
i watched it and like i'll never be able
to unsee like all those images so it's
like i'm kind of like
i don't know it might not bother me that
much i'm kind of yeah they're saying at
least
because the movie should be it should be
whatever yeah
said well here's the thing here's the
thing
you go back and watch those now and
they're a lot better than a lot of the
[ __ ] that's come out like [ __ ]
terminator dark fate and all that kind
of [ __ ]
there's a lot more heart in in that
second
avp2 than there is in
like i said terminator dark fate yeah
they're a lot better than that and
[ __ ] avp1 is a lot better than dark
faith
and so people were really complaining
about them at the time
but you could watch that now that's a
lot better than the [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's been coming out of hollywood the
past two or three years
it's been pretty bad there's been a
couple of good ones
but it's been all indie flicks vivarium
[ __ ]
i really like that [ __ ] those two
what's his name eisenberg yeah jesse
either jesse eisenberg i like his movies
i like the movies he wants to do
i like vivarium i like [ __ ] we
watched vamarium again the other night
and i liked it just as much the second
time
varium is a weird horror [ __ ] sci-fi
flick
it's like predator but very different is
alien gets you makes you raise its baby
that's a weird [ __ ] and
i just liked it yeah i did too it wasn't
an action movie but it was just like
you're in this [ __ ] trap you got
trapped in this thing
in a parallel dimension that looks like
a [ __ ] suburban landscape
made by aliens extra dimensional aliens
they're [ __ ] you up making you raise
their baby it's weird man
uh no i haven't i have not seen the vast
of night yet it's still on my list but i
haven't seen it yet
so many people have recommended it and i
really need to get around to it so it's
like it's on my list i just haven't got
to it yet but i promise i will
and we'll probably review it like as
soon as i see it um but yeah all right
so we'll be back
tomorrow doing another matinee live
stream of another new movie
so uh thanks you guys for stopping by
and discussing stuff with us
and we'll see you guys bye we got